today we are here with BuzzFeed to test
our knowledge on the original Hunger
Games oh no we all going to wrun and how
are you going to do you know how you
going to do it's a competition just
before this she was just bragging about
so you better all three of the original
books are under my chair because I was
reading them before we start a few
minutes later I got three out of eight
correct I know the answers you got three
yeah I got four I got four as well how
did we guys did it eight out of eight
the aim so actually because we're we
just like collecting our points against
you it's we got eight and you got three
it's embarrassing I am embarrassed of
who I am should be thank you BuzzFeed um
thanks BuzzFeed for that